construit entre le 11e et le 14e siècle
sur les hauteurs de chevreuse pour
contrôler la voie paris chartres le
château de la madeleine attire
aujourd'hui de nombreux curieux
guidés par stéphane loriot petits et
grands découvrent une période
passionnante abordée sous différentes
facettes
on l'a fait de la botanique on a parlé
de vie comment dire davy cotiser en
termes de commandes ou comment on
dormait donc comment comment on
bataillait comment se soigner etc et on
a compris que le moyen âge est une
période extrêmement riche que celle
sonde les renaissances voilà successives
et que la vie quotidienne au moyen âge
basse et ça nous permet de comprendre un
peu plus de monde vient où on va les
moines avaient des livres très anciens
qu'il recopiait donc il y avait cette
force d'avoir des bouquins en plus mais
globalement le médiéval de manière
globale un vraiment il avait une
connaissance botanique qu'aujourd'hui on
a vraiment vraiment perdu et qu'on
s'acharne pour certains a retrouvé une
connaissances botaniques que stéphane
initié au groupe de visites notamment en
leur présentant les bienfaits de la
médecine par les plantes sauvages et de
la médecine moderne commence un petit
peu arrivent à saturation je dirais et
la médecine par les plantes ou se
nourrir avec des plantes sauvages c'est
revient au goût du jour
pas que pour un effet mode pas parce que
c'est rigolo pas parce que c'est gratuit
nan parce qu'effectivement on pratique
une résilience vraiment vraiment
intelligente qui nous permet de
s'affranchir de traitement qui n'ont
plus cours parce que dangereux avec des
dégâts collatéraux que nos couleurs a
quasiment jamais avec les plantes
sauvages donc pour les pathologies
légères moyennes ou même lourdes les
plantes seront toujours là pour nous
accompagner tout le temps vous prenez
pour faire court trois plantes très
basique très connus comme l'ortie la
berce et le pissenlit est assis ne
fallait manger que ça sur une année à ne
faire que ça pour s'amuser à 5,6 et le
terme nous n'aurions aucune carence
alimentaire toutes ces plantes sauvages
autour de nous sur lesquels nous pietà
lyon là elles sont la pâle nous colle se
planter sont vraiment à notre service
est bien profiter en comprendre la vie
médiévale tout en faisant la
connaissance de plantes sauvages scène
et ne produisant aucun dégât collatéral
dans leur consommation
voilà de quoi satisfaire tous les
visiteurs du château